oh
oh
i know
oh
before we go to our classes
i want to say
as your student medical advisor
one final word about tuberculosis
we as negroes seem to be particularly
susceptible to this disease
the reason is the great majority of our
homes are poor
and our work hard
and we don't have money to get treated
when we should now if you have any of
the symptoms of tuberculosis
such as coughing
unusual fatigue a loss of weight
go at once to a physician for an
examination
tuberculosis can be cured but only if
treatment is started soon enough
thank you dr gordon
thus we close our negro health week
service
hello
hello george
this is mary
yes your sister
george mama's very sick
your doctor says you're gonna come right
home
what's the matter
my mother's very sick
she has tuberculosis
she's had it for years
but she'd never see a doctor
i have to go home
thanks
i won't forget this
see
me
mary
me
so
them
the lord giveth them the lord take it
away
the lord giveth from the lord take it
away but oh lord let my people live
come in sister
well
she was a good woman miss baxter
she had tuberculosis
consumption she called it
unscathed
they say it runs in the family
no
i don't know that it mean that at all
some people think that tuberculosis can
be passed down from mother to child
that's not true
i'm not a doctor
but i've read a lot about tuberculosis
it comes from a germ it's passed along
by contact of one person with another
well i have a scene sit through my mind
i have a course
i feel tired like she did all the time
i can't eat
that's not so good
what can i do
you be smart
you go to see a doctor
if you can't afford that go to a clinic
the doctor will test you and tell you
whether or not you have tuberculosis
if he says no that's fine
if he says yes
do exactly what he tells you
but don't let anyone tell you that
tuberculosis can't be cured
all right
i'll go to see dr gordon tomorrow
good evening
thank you
hello larry
where are you going it's dr gordon
um
i noticed you got the same thing your
mother had ain't you
i'm not sure minnie i've got to find out
listen honey ain't no use you've fool
yourself no you got it well i have to
get treated who's going in there
girl ain't no doctor in the world can
kill you you know the burglar well who
can
my grandma can you see
she makes a special kind of a tea out of
herbs and roots is sucking for your nose
oh construction's gone
she don't charge half as much as this
doctor does neither my mother believes
in that roots herbs and cheese i've got
to see dr gordon girl
i'm getting better george
dr gordon said i was so sensible to come
to see him so early
george
how about you
of course you went with mama as much as
i was but you might have caught it too
oh i'm all right
you may feel all right
george why don't you run over let dr
gordon look you over
he's a real doctor
promise me you will
well
maybe i will
well i don't hear anything but we're not
through here
sit down man
what's that for doctor i'm going to put
a drop of this solution into your arm
it's called tuberculin
now in two days if the spot where i make
the injection is raised and rinsed it
means that at one time in your life
tuberculosis germs got into your body
oh it didn't hurt a bit doc
how does it look doctor
hmm
positive does that mean i have
tuberculosis no but i'm going to send
you to a hospital to have an x-ray made
here's a picture of your chest
now that spot there is what we call a
primary tuber
it means that the germs got into your
lungs at one time
maybe long ago but you would help and
your body took care gee
i'm glad to hear that
what you've got to do now is to keep
your good health don't use up too much
of your energy either in work or
are staying out late at night
eat well-balanced meals and get plenty
of fresh air if the danger sign of
fatigue coughing loss of weight or pains
in the chest appear don't fail to come
in and see me
thanks
doctor i'm certainly glad to know i
haven't got it
oh
how is mary getting along well she's
getting the very best of care to send
her to him and she'll be well pretty
soon now she
that's swell
now you see why it's so important that
tuberculosis be discovered early
every young person from 15 to 25 should
have a two point one test and an x-ray
you see they may find as you did that
they need only rest and care or they may
find that their loans like your sisters
need treatment right away
the quicker they know and the sooner
they get treated the better their
chances are to get well this is
especially true of our days many of us
wait too long before starting treatment
we must teach our people that
tuberculosis is curable and we must show
them that every person with tuberculosis
is administered to his family if his
case isn't put under a doctor at once
thanks doctor
you make me see things in a different
light
i feel as though i were right hand
it's too bad mary you couldn't go down
to see george graduate
but just think how lucky you are
you are well and have a good job
yes i wish mama were here
i almost think i hear george's boys
my
me
oh
you